sometimes a movies production just goes
so off the rails that the most humane
thing the filmmakers can do is to pull
the plug these are some previously
announced and greatly anticipated movies
that reach the end of the line in 2019
over the course of nearly 20 years the
x-men movie franchise placed its
ensemble cast of mutants in different
points across various timelines
Wolverine was the first character to
spin-off into his own sub franchise with
x-men origins Wolverine the Wolverine
and Logan for years Fox tried to get
more standalone mutant movies off the
ground starting with a proposed origins
follow-up focusing on Magneto though
this project was eventually reworked
into the ensemble prequel x-men first
class the other solo X movie that's come
close to being a reality is one about
Remy LeBeau
aka gambit the Louisiana born staff
wielding mutant who's notably adept at
throwing explosive playing cards gambit
is a fan favorite having been a main
character in the 90s Saturday morning
x-men cartoon even made a brief
appearance in x-men origins Wolverine
are you removable
do I owe you money no then women LeBeau
I have Fox stacked the deck for the
film's chances by casting likeable
bankable Channing Tatum in the title
role but the studio just couldn't get
this movie into play thanks to a
seemingly never-ending search for the
right director to helmet
gambit had been shuffled around a couple
of 2019 release dates but the ongoing
director search left its viability in
question as 2019 began Fox had gambit
scheduled for release in March 2020
despite not having a director actively
attached then Disney acquired Fox
throwing the smaller Studios whole slate
of projects into disarray in may 20 19
the new bosses moved around the release
dates for a bunch of movies including
gambit the tatum vehicle went from a
March 2020 release to currently nothing
disappearing from the schedule the
enduring Star Trek big-screen franchise
flew high four decades after focusing on
the characters from the original 1960s
TV series the movies shifted focus to
the world of Star Trek The Next
Generation ultimately sputtering out
when the 2002 entry Star Trek nemesis
grossed 43 million dollars the worst
ever showing for a trek movie it took
the visionary sci-fi mind of JJ Abrams
to revive Star Trek movies for a new
generation reviving well-known
old-school characters like Kirk and
Spock to create three fun and
contemporary blockbusters Star Trek star
trek into darkness and star trek beyond
the last one earned 158 million dollars
in the summer of 2016 enough to merit a
fourth entry paramount announced the
project at CinemaCon
2018 with SJ clarkson attached to direct
Zachary Quinto was reportedly up to
reprise his role as Spock and Chris
Hemsworth may have returned to having
played Captain Kirk's father George in
2009 Star Trek not immediately on board
however it was Chris Pine the guy that
plays the fairly important role of
Captain Kirk Pine and paramount couldn't
come to an agreement on a contract and
the same issue occurred when trying to
sign Hemsworth the studio ultimately
cancelled the entire movie amidst the
21st century's zombie craze that gave us
the Walking Dead and pride in
zombies came World War Z based on the
novel by Max Brooks the movie starred
Brad Pitt as a globe trekking military
aligned hero trying to stop the zombie
hordes running all over the world with
their insatiable lust for flesh the film
ended with a hopeful ish ending and it
grossed a whopping 202 million dollars
at the North American box office
ensuring a sequel World War Z too seemed
more promising than any other
unnecessary sequels if only because
seven and Fight Club director David
Fincher was reportedly on board to
direct there were vague rumors of a
20-19 release date and according to the
playlist paramount did everything it
could to get the ball rolling but it
never officially gave the thing the
greenlight everything fell apart and as
of February 2019 will dwars e2 crawled
back into the grave sequels and prequels
are common movie conceits but crossover
movies not so much the most prominent
modern mashup of two established
properties on the big screen is probably
alien vs. predator Sony hoped to pull
off a faceoff of its own with two of its
hit comedy brands men in black and Jump
Street news of this proposed film hit
the streets via the 2014 Sony hack in
one leaked document studio co-chair Amy
Pascal floated the idea and in an email
jump streets Jonah Hill called the idea
quote clean and red and powerful Sony
continued to develop the idea and at
CinemaCon 2016 announced that the film
would be titled MIB 23 and that James
Bobin would direct but just a few months
later he'll seem to find the project
neither rad nor powerful he told the
Toronto Sun I doubt that movie will get
made the Jump Street films were so fun
to make and the whole joke of them was
that they were making fun of remakes and
sequels and reboots and then now it's
become a giant sequel reboot in January
2019 MIB producer Walter parks admitted
it was all over
telling Empire quote we gave it a shot
he went on to explain that the whole
thing turned out to be a quote
impossible matchup while Disney owned
Marvel proceeded full steam ahead with
its Marvel Cinematic Universe Sony
remained determined to hold on to their
movie rights to spider-man the MCU solo
Spidey stories starring Tom Holland are
co-productions between
Sony and Marvel but Sony has also been
focusing on spin-offs centered primarily
around offshoot characters in
spider-man's corner of the Marvel
Universe
among those films are the oscar-winning
animated feature into the spider-verse
the hit venom starring Tom Hardy in the
upcoming Morbius with Jared Leto
portraying the living vampire or
whatever the heck that is there was also
a proposed endeavor called silver and
black that film would showcase the
adventures of not one but two
spider-man's side characters mercenaries
silver sable and cat-burglar black cat
you look good been working out oh I mean
you know a little in May 2017 Sony
signed up Gina Prince Blythewood to
direct and charged ahead for a February
2019 we state that changed in June 2018
when the studio altered its theatrical
debut date to no date at all there had
been a few problems along the way
primarily that shooting hadn't yet begun
one of the main problems reportedly was
that the director didn't like the
shooting script no screenplay and no
release date usually imply a movie is
dead but that's not exactly the case
here shortly after silver and black lost
its street date Sony announced that it
would instead make two separate movies
one silver one black hey the more the
merrier right check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]